c'est du jamais vu des millions
d'habitants placés en quarantaine
les autorités chinoises ont bouclé ce
matin trois villes rurales des images
saisissantes fin janvier 2020 pour
enrayer la propagation du nouveau
coronavirus 56 millions de chinois de la
province du hubei et de sa capitale
orane sont confinés en france on est
encore loin de cette situation pour le
moment une centaine de français
seulement sont confinés préventivement à
carry le rouet première journée en
quarantaine mais sous le soleil de la
méditerranée
pour les 180 rapatriés de hauranne
balade sur le front de mer
on repose sur les transats discussions à
l'ombre de la pinède empêcher la
pénétration du virus sur le territoire
c'est le stade 1 du plan de gestion
français contre le courant n'a virus fin
février avec l'apparition des premiers
cluster sur le territoire le stade de
est activée comme ici dans l'oise plus
de broc lente plus de marché plus de
théâtre plus de matchs de foot plus de
mariages plus de messe la commune de
creil va devoir apprendre à vivre au
ralenti comme partout dans l'oise dans
tout le département les rassemblements
collectifs sont désormais interdits ces
semis confinement se multiplient sur le
territoire mais reste à l'échelle locale
et le 4 mars le gouvernement n'imaginent
toujours pas un confinement général les
métros continueront à circuler jusqu'à
nouvel ordre les transports en commun
continueront à circuler jusqu'à nouvel
ordre et la vie du pays ne s'arrêtera
pas pourtant à nos portes la vie
s'arrête l'italie du nord est confiné le
8 mars ce même jour le professeur eric
comme tire la sonnette d'alarmé
il faut s'inspirer de ce qui se passe en
italie il n'y a aucune raison que la
france fasse mieux que les italiens
or ce qui se passe en italie doit nous
inquiéter le 14 mars le gouvernement
active le troisième et dernier stade du
plan contre locaux vides tout le système
hospitalier est en alerte
après la fermeture des écoles les
restaurants cinémas café musées doivent
aussi fermer leurs portes mais pour
cette virologue
il faut encore aller plus loin me
continue en général me semble nécessaire
parce qu'on est dans une situation où le
nombre de cas double tous les trois
jours c'est la seule façon de briser les
chaînes de transmission le 16 mars 2020
au soir emmanuel macron annonce
l'instauration d'un confinement strict
sur tout le territoire français
j'ai décidé de renforcer encore les
mesures pour réduire nos déplacements et
nos contacts au strict nécessaire
le confinement du printemps 2020 va
durer jusqu'au 11 mai soit un mois et 25
jours
[Musique]